[Music]
hey
everyone welcome to another installment
of harry potter theory
in this video we're going to be digging
deep into harry potter law
and taking a look at an evil wizard that
you've probably never heard of
his name was moen the malicious not to
be confused with the good wizard merlin
mo and malicious was an evil and i mean
evil
pure blood wizard that existed sometime
between the 5th
and 15th centuries aka the medieval
period
this is the same period of history that
produced many notable witches and
wizards
like the founders of hogwarts salazar
cytherin godric gryffindor
rowena ravenclaw helga hufflepuff and
others
like merlin and morgana le fay i find it
particularly interesting
that this time period was responsible
for so many powerful witches and wizards
the hogwarts founders after all were
thought to possess powers that are
uncomparable to most modern day witches
and wizards
and people like merlin morgana were more
powerful than them
this means that given that merwin made
it into the history books as an evil
wizard
during this time period he must have
truly been a force to be reckoned with
in harry potter when we think of evil
witches and wizards
we usually think of voldemort
grindelwald bellatrix
etc but in reality the wizarding world
has been around for a very very long
time
and over the course of history there
have been an uncountable number of
powerful dark forces
some of them rose to prominence and had
big plans to take over the wizarding
world
and others quietly experimented with the
dark arts in isolation
these wizards include people like who
may have been responsible for creating
the dementors
rexidian who was destroyed by his own
magic when he attempted to produce a
patronus charm
and morgana leffe perhaps the most
powerful dark witch in history
who opposed merlin the most powerful
wizard of history
these are all such enigmatic figures in
wizarding lore
and history and i love to dig deep and
research these figures
because they are an integral part of the
formation of the present day wizarding
world
which is why today we're going to be
looking at another powerful
evil dark wizard that existed during the
same time period
as a lot of these other guys moen the
malicious
now i'll be frank there's not a whole
lot of information on merwin out there
but i included every little tidbit that
i could find first things first we know
of mo when the malicious
because he was like other wizards have
been immortalized in the wizarding world
after his death
how was he immortalized you might ask
well he was immortalized in a couple of
ways
the first and most notable being his
chocolate frog card
that's right merwin was featured on his
very own chocolate frog card
much like dumbledore mokano le faye and
many others
chocolate fog cards are of course
trading cards that display pictures of
famous witches and wizards
and provide small amounts of information
about them to be featured on a chocolate
frog card
you really need to be a notable figure
they don't just feature anyone
which is sort of what sparked my
curiosity about mowing
the second way that merwin was
immortalized was through a portrait in
hogwarts
his portrait can be found guarding a
secret shortcut between the third floor
landing of the grand staircase
and the entrance hall side room the
password for this entrance is
malevolence which is fitting given
merwin's character
during his lifetime moen was a dedicated
practitioner of the dark arts and would
conduct all sorts of twisted magical
experiments
using his uniquely hooked wand he had
dark grey scabby looking skin
which sort of resembled lifeless human
skin and would often support a long
dark green cloak he was a scary looking
guy and i have no doubt that the
experiments he would conduct
had a lasting effect on his physical
appearance as we know how dark magic can
affect you in that way
from all of his experiments merwin
obtained notoriety by his creation of
dark spells
jinxers and hexes he is largely
responsible for many of the dark curses
and spells
that came to prevalence during the
medieval period and i suspect
that a lot of the dark spells that we
see today were his doing
after all spell creation is how he made
it on
to a chocolate frog card moment is
commonly associated with hogwarts
founder
salazar slitherin who was likely born
sometime around 9 50
a.d though southern contributed some
good to the world
in the form of his involvement with
hogwarts school he was also quite an
evil man
and a notable dark figure during the
time period that he existed
slytherin was extremely powerful and
casting dark charms and spells
and he was notably skilled at legitimacy
wand making
basilisk breeding and charms having
helped to create the sorting hat
there's no doubt in my mind that merwin
and salazar met at one point or another
but one intriguing theory that i've seen
suggests that there is a familial
connection
between them could mo and the militias
be from the slytherin family as well
could he be a distant relative of
voldemort
unfortunately when merwin died there
still wasn't much information known
about him
and his body was never found this makes
connecting him to slytherin difficult
but it's a fun theory and i think
there's totally a possibility
and that's all i've got on mo in the
militias did you guys know about him
do you think he's related to slytherin
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
[Music]
harry
you